série jalu chaloupe
il s'est passé quelque chose il ya un
instant illusion
voilà plus de là qu'il est beau ici on
va pas vous montrer les images qu'on va
utiliser pour joly allez si le dollar
valait ces produits là je sens que tout
le monde on adore voir je vais expliquer
j'ai expliqué le contexte mais jean lui
parce que expliquera mieux le contexte
la semaine prochaine dans les quatre
tirs à votre mère est folle escapade
joueuses étaient en train de danser au
moment où j'ai dit à mathieu delormeau
viens danser aussi hélas est-ce qu'on a
les images où il fait le beau tout ça et
après la le le délire on l'a ou pas avec
le son est tout aussi vous plaindre j
quant aux téléspectateurs en résumé non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas possible il va doubler de
volume
qu'est-ce qu'il a une fois qu'à une
chose qui double de volume chez vous 250
250 les 250 buts que vous avez pris dans
une émission hier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
continuez à l'horaire go 250 go to build
a oui on a mal compris vous avez bateau
fait vraiment l'esprit malsain cm ça
fait combien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle a démonté écoliers volontaires
c'est vrai mais d'après vous mettez
toujours des beaux bijoux comme ça passe
comme les offres non mais c'est passé
pour parce que je vous trouvez que ça ça
vous va bien je vous ai toujours dit
plus le centre devient moche plus faut
attirer l'attention
et
vous avez une question à poser à
isabelle mathieu attention clarin qui se
repose et donc sans risque
je voulais savoir si aujourd'hui il y
avait beaucoup de succès avec les hommes
aujourd'hui oui oui c'est la tranche
d'âge qui a changé mais isabelle vous
par exemple mathieu est ce qui vous
aurez plus physiquement mais j'aime bien
les roues vous savez oui mais à l'époque
à l'époque oui à l'époque j'aimais déjà
les roues à l'époque the tu comment
laisser jean luc sans à l'époque n'était
pas rouillé mais j'aimais déjà les roues
pourquoi il ya un truc qui va du tout à
l'époque
à l'époque vous trouviez comment à
l'époque eux
malcom estime à 2 0 on a parié dans les
loges elle sortirait ces deux phrases à
l'audition à l'époque j'étais contexte
il n'en est rien merci mme isabelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]